let's see if we can squeeze in some
somebody else here let's go to the four
seven zero area code caller from four
seven zero who's this hello that's you
oh wow oh gosh I'm nervous it's nice to
meet you
let's just with if you can tell us
okay aim that would be great if we're on
some kind of speaker please do take us
off Oh King hear me my name is Cameron
I'm from Atlanta Georgia and I just
wanted to know just get a quick
background I was at a location I was
talking to someone and then another
person chimed in a relative of that
person I was talking to and there was
three things that bothered me when we're
talking one was welfare abuse and
because it increased taxes we should we
get rid of paying taxes for welfare
because of wealth there's too much
welfare abuse does that exist there was
this immigration unequal health care
treatment and immigrants fault which led
to some race war that there's a race war
something about that that that conquer
certainly and the third one was what
from the movie Michaels a movie that I
just recently watch was can you
citizen's arrest a federal official
whether it be a governor or even as far
as a president okay let's take these one
by one if we can so the last one is can
you citizen's arrest a federal official
or the president I think in it
conceivably you could but it's not going
to happen and I don't advise you to try
okay I'm not saying that's just an idea
okay cool down as far as is there
welfare abuse what do you meet you are
you saying like are there any people who
get welfare benefits who don't deserve
them based on the guidelines is that the
question yeah come when I was talking I
was like welfare abuse and I was talking
to another person on my relative my
family rested and saying that we know
people that are in welfare abuse like
they're just too lazy and I was thinking
with that I I don't know the facts I'm
disappointing because let's slow down a
little bit
so you could have someone who is lying
about their income or circumstances in
order to get welfare benefits that
they're not actually entitled to then
separately from that there might be
people who are just lazy but are legally
entitled to those welfare benefits which
of the two are you talking about now
okay
what I'm talking about and I'm from this
conversation I'm talking about
he was talking about that because people
are just lazy who for the welfare which
people people in welfare like the
majority of welfare people were in
welfare they're just too lazy and we're
paying we're paying our taxes okay good
all right to pay em relief Cameron here
that that warning here's what I want to
advise you when this person you were
talking to said that what how did you
respond now I can't even come on I can't
even hear how did how did you respond
you hear me now yeah can't hear me now
yeah okay I didn't say anything cuz I
really didn't have much to say which I'm
disappointed I'm a fan of your show okay
I should know these facts got it so
here's the thing they're making the
claim that all these people on welfare
are quote lazy so the first question is
how do you define laziness because then
if they say well they don't work then
you can say actually most poor people
work and most people on some kind of
government welfare actually do work and
you can find a citation that works for
you if they say I define lazy as they
don't really care about getting off of
the welfare program then then you can
tackle that but the most important thing
is make them prove it right say what
evidence do you have that most people on
welfare are lazy because if they say
well my cousins on welfare and they're
lazy you say we're talking about a
country of three hundred and forty
million people you you make your
decisions based on your cousin yeah yeah
yeah it all stinks and it was not not
just that but I'm saying from this
person this pie I don't know those guys
life as much as it was like a casual
conversation that led to some sort of
little argument so they got and I got
there just like I like you recently
talked about you had casual
conversations
and it's just like would you talk to the
other guy how a lot of people are
spewing what they claim as facts yeah
but I don't think they have enough
information about it but hey that's a
double-edged sword
yeah all right Cameron thank you
appreciate the call longing to know Rob
topics there thank you thank you
that does it for calls today sorry to
everybody I didn't get to but the phone
lines have just been jammed lately we
will take calls again and I appreciate
everybody who called in thank you so
much